[Music]
thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
live from New York our top story
in court
fingerprinted and fighting for his
political life Donald Trump pleads not
guilty to 34 five counts of falsifying
business records
a scheme to buy and suppress negative
information to help Mr Trump's chance of
winning the election
up in the air no words from Mr Trump yet
but he now heads home to have his say
from the courthouse to the clubhouse
from the courthouse to the clubhouse and
his home state of Florida the former
president continues to divide Americans
I love it I want to see them handcuffed
I want to see him in an orange suit it
is embarrassing for America to do the
canister to our president
also tonight a new era begins
welcome
to the alliance
[Applause]
a major setback for Vladimir Putin is
Finland which shares an 832 mile border
with Russia becomes the 31st member of
NATO
a mother and her partner who she called
a monster have been found guilty over
the death of two-year-old Lola James
say no to the flotel conservative MPS
and local residents on the south coast
try to sink a proposal for new offshore
accommodation for migrants
and we will take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
[Music]
good evening from New York where Donald
Trump became the first store current the
first current or former president to be
charged with a crime marking a new
chapter in American history
he has pleaded not guilty to 34 felony
counts of falsifying business records
for his alleged role in hush money
payments to two women towards the end of
his 2016 electoral campaign
out through his golden doors Donald J
Trump his body language on the face of
it defiance America's 45th president but
the first to face A Moment Like This
from every angle history recorded the
Convoy to bring a president from his
Penthouse to the dock
and so here it is a Journey Begins a
president goes to court
and as the Convoy headed south through
Manhattan he was of course online this
time with words that reflect the moment
well perfectly so surreal he wrote from
the car wow they're going to arrest me
can't believe this is happening in
America but so it did
50 or so blocks south a wave and then
steps into the history books steps that
no American president has taken before
away from the cameras he was
fingerprinted but not handcuffed and no
mug shot and then into the courtroom
we even speak to US president Trump
inside video banned but the images tell
the story flanked by his defense team
Donald Trump listened to the charges
against him 34 counts 16 pages and three
different instances where he is accused
of paying money to keep people quiet not
guilty he pleaded outside the world
absorbed the charges unsealed for the
first time among them cash for a Trump
Tower doorman relating to a child born
out of wedlock cash for a woman who
claimed she'd had sex with the president
and that money for Stormy Daniels the
porn star paid off just days before he
won the election in 2016.
the president departed with no words
they were left for his lawyers a team
who now know the details of the case
they say they will fight today's
unsealing of this indictment shows that
the rule of law died in this country
because well everyone is not above the
law no one's below it either and if this
man's name was not Donald J Trump there
is no scenario we'd all be here today
please understand that based on these
charges
over the road in the park all the
president's supporters led by
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green
and drowned out by the other side a
snapshot of the division that comes with
every twist in the Trump story
it gets unprecedented
they say what he did was illegal
you support him all the way as
well
what do you make of what's Happening
Here I think it's the greatest thing to
happen he deserves it it's about time to
sucker got caught I don't think the
president's above the law but I think
that if you look at the evidence
president Trump did nothing wrong in the
situation this is a Witch Hunt
leading the establishment Witch Hunt
they allege Alvin Bragg the district
attorney whose sights have always been
on Mr Trump he had his moment
34 false statements
made to cover up other crimes
these are felony crimes in New York
state
no matter who you are
we cannot and will not normalize serious
criminal conducts
day of History written and so much more
to come the former president the man who
could still be again was off back to
Florida and Mar-A-Lago Mark Stone Sky
News in New York
let's take a look now at some of the
standout charges that were outlined
today
12 days before the presidential general
election the indictment alleges that a
lawyer for Donald Trump covertly paid a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars to
an adult film actress
after winning the election Trump
reimbursed that lawyer through a series
of monthly checks
Trump orchestrated his catch and kill
scheme through a series of payments that
he then concealed through months of
false business entries
he allegedly paid thirty thousand
dollars to a former Trump Tower Dormer
who claimed to have a story about a
child that Trump had out of wedlock
allegedly Emi the country's largest
tabloid publisher who's chairman is a
close Ally of President Trump paid a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars to a
woman who alleged she had a sexual
relationship with Donald Trump
Mark Stone my colleague is here with me
now
Mark history when it's happening before
your eyes never feels quite like history
I would today feel to you so true so
true what a day uh what a spectacle what
a series of moments from the moment we
saw Donald Trump emerge from Trump Tower
um the the cameras the U.S networks
following every step of the way down
here to the bottom end of Manhattan and
then walking in
um to this austere Courthouse such a
such a long way from the White House
such a long way from the penthouse in
Trump Tower I was struck by his demeanor
this is a man who who clearly wants to
make a victim of himself he is a man who
can't resist appearing in front of the
cameras can't resist speaking there were
cameras in those corridors you saw in my
report people tried to ask him to speak
to approach those cameras but today no
today he was downbeat I thought as he
walked into that courtroom The Stills
Still photographs they told a thousand
words didn't they and they will be the
front pages of every newspaper around
the world tomorrow an extraordinary Day
history made The Reluctant Shoma it's
not like him mark thank you very much
indeed well Donald Trump may have been
in a court today but it's in the court
of public opinion where his political
future will perhaps be decided despite
the ongoing controversy that has
followed him since he left the White
House he remains many voters top joints
for the top job at the next presidential
election in the early hours of tomorrow
morning he will deliver remarks from his
Florida base to Rally his supporters and
perhaps add to the millions of dollars
already raised in contributions since
the indictment was announced
from Florida our U.S correspondent
Martha Kellner now Republicans
famously Donald Trump's favorite pastime
but just a few miles from his front door
opinions on the fairways are fiercely
divided on his indictment what does it
make you think that a former president
is charged with a crime I love it I want
to see him handcuffed I want to see him
in an orange suit
I think he deserves everything he gets
Sue and her girlfriends remember a time
when Trump running for president was
treated as a joke here almost a decade
on he's in the dock he's a crook he's a
thief we knew that before he ever got in
office
but people voted him in and he still has
followers and I would say that even if
he ran for president there's a good
chance he could still get in
plenty of people here would still vote
for Donald Trump in 2024 if he gets the
Republican nomination
Clubhouse manager and snack bar
attendant Tony the Tiger Lopez came to
the U.S from Mexico 43 years ago Donald
Trump became the best president ever in
in ever in the United States and it is
embarrassing for America
to do the canister to our president so
charged with a serious crime doesn't
affect the way you think about him I
believe it's political
I may not vote for Donald Trump long
voted for Trump in 2020 but might look
elsewhere next time but still he thinks
the criminal charges against him are
politically motivated they're just
walking to put some put some incidents
out there and if they stick fine if they
don't
they haven't they don't have anything to
lose
because they're not their names aren't
being dragged through the mud even as
his fingerprints are being taken Trump
is collecting millions of dollars in
donations from his loyal base
polls show he is still the driving force
in the Republican party I have friends
that mean nafik they had him on video
shooting somebody and killing somebody
they would still support them the round
of golf continues so too does the drama
Division and debate which has ever
surrounds Donald Trump Martha Kellner
Sky News Florida
so what happens next we'll hear from
Donald Trump himself very soon at around
1 15 a.m UK time when he returns to his
Mar-A-Lago home in Florida to address
supporters who've gathered there we will
bring you that live here on Sky News
his next court appearance is scheduled
for December the 4th with any trial
likely to start in January next year
however Trump's lawyers say they expect
to file motions to the court to dismiss
the case outright they have 45 days to
do so
but this case isn't his only legal worry
there are separate criminal probes into
claims he unlawfully tried to overturn
his 2020 election defeat
in Georgia that was indeed and over his
handling of classified documents after
leaving office
and of course he could also Face action
over his alleged role in inciting the
attack by his supporters on the Capitol
building in Washington on January the
6th 2021.
we were looking ahead to Donald Trump's
speech in Florida in the early hours of
the morning later in the program but now
back to Kamali for the rest of today's
news
James thank you now when Vladimir Putin
invaded Ukraine one of his strategic
goals was to prevent what he saw as the
encroachment of NATO into his sphere of
influence today just over a year on
Finland became the alliances 31st member
the Kremlin has vowed to respond to the
expansion now tomorrow Ukraine's present
Vladimir zelenski will visit key NATO
member Poland from where our Europe
correspondent chiffon Robbins reports
this is exactly what President Putin
didn't want to see a new flag raised at
NATO HQ
avoiding the expansion of this military
Alliance was one of the reasons Russia
gave for invading Ukraine ironically
that act of aggression is what triggered
Finland to join
first important wanted to slam NATO's
door shut
today we show the world that he failed
that aggression and intimidation do not
work
after Decades of being neutral Finns now
firmly back NATO
with a strong capable military finland's
new membership packs a punch
a point not lost on the Kremlin whose
defense minister warned it will take
countermeasures
membership will create a risk of
expanding the conflict he said but won't
affect the outcome of the special
operation
and it's easy to see why Russia is
worried
all of these countries are already in
NATO and if you add Finland you
basically double the NATO border with
Russia and reinforce this Eastern flank
add Sweden which is currently being
blocked by turkey and you can hold the
Baltic Sea like many on the Eastern
Front Poland Bears the scars of Soviet
atrocities
here they say finland's membership makes
all of its NATO neighbors safer a major
blow to Russia so Finland joining NATO
is a big step towards peace in Europe
because Finland joining NATO reduces the
possibility of Russia attacking another
European country
now this Alliance stands at 31 by the
end of the year it could be 32. Putin's
aggression has only strengthened his
enemy Siobhan Robbins Sky News Poland
a mother and her partner have been found
guilty over the death of a two-year-old
girl Carl Bevin who is 31 was found
guilty of murdering his partner's
daughter Lola James in Haverford West
Lola's mother Sinead James was found
guilty of causing or allowing the
toddler's death now during the trial she
know James described Evan as a Monster
who needs to rot in hell Becky Johnson
reports
Lola James had been a happy toddler
until her mother's new partner moved in
within weeks Lola had unexplained
bruises then early one morning he
murdered her and filmed her as she Lay
Dying of more than a hundred injuries
he'd inflicted Kyle Bevin then woke
Lola's mother and lied that the dog had
knocked her down the stairs she called
an ambulance to their home in Haverford
West in pembrokeshire
just to consider
to confessions
so does she wait up when you respond
when you try and make her she like me
was one of these when I tried to wake up
her eyes
okay
I'm really scared
as Lola was rushed to hospital Bevin
repeated his lie about her falling to
police
the fact that I was making a purpose
Bevan had moved into the squalid home in
February 2020 the same month Social
Services had visited and raised concerns
about the condition of the house but the
authorities didn't return as the country
went into covert lockdown
a stained child Swansea was found by
police when they searched the filthy
home
Lola's mother Sinead James was convicted
of causing or allowing Lola's death
Bevin was found guilty of murder this is
a horrendous heinous crime it was a
sustained violent abusive assault of a
defenseless two-year-old child Lola's
father on the right had a statement read
on his behalf the pain and grief I feel
every time I close my eyes and see your
perfect little face is unbearable the
pain I feel thinking of all the smiles
you gave to me and all the smiles I
won't get a chance to give back to you
hurt so much
even to say your name shutters my heart
to know you can't hear my voice anymore
like Arthur labinjo Hughes and star
Hobson Lola was abused and murdered
while the country was in lockdown the
children's charity the nspcc has said a
review must establish if more could have
been done by the authorities to prevent
her death Becky Johnson Sky News
now a giant barge that was once used by
the Dutch governments to house Asylum
Seekers could reportedly be leased by
the home office its intended location is
dorsi and the local Tory MP called The
Proposal utterly out of the question it
comes after similar dissent over plans
to keep migrants at military bases and
Essex and Lincolnshire Ashner huronak
reports Bibi Stockholm offers a
completely unique approach to
accommodating your Workforce this
promotional video shows off what the
government hopes will be its answer to
the migration issue over 200 bedrooms
with ensuites a bar and a gym all on a
barge that could be moored here on
Portland home of the Jurassic Coast
and home two to Sally and her locals who
are wary of the idea Portland's always
been so laid back I think they've chosen
it as an easy option but I think you'll
find you're going to have a big uproar
against this two doctors surgeries here
we've got those of us who live here now
can't get an appointment for over two
weeks
and Wayne agree that local services are
stretched they've lived here all their
lives and say there's not enough to go
around we just don't want it here really
a lot of the locals All Humans aren't
being treated equally
the locals wherever these people are
going have been completely forgotten
about the homeless of being forgotten
about
the first time that Portland Harbor has
housed static floating accommodation up
until 2005 the prison hmp Weir was
docked here now there's a very real
possibility that this island could
become home to hundreds of Asylum
Seekers
which the local MP says could discourage
tourism to an area that depends on it he
says specially built facilities in urban
areas could be the answer land-based
reception centers are going to have to
be built whether we're located or not
yes it's going to cost money but I
suspect in the in the longer term it'll
cost less than what we're doing now
which is Hotel ships barges etc etc
he is considering legal action like
those opposing Lincolnshire military
base RAF scampton being turned into
temporary accommodation but the
government says these are realistic
Solutions well there's a cost of about
six million pounds a day that we are
spending on accommodation for people in
this country who are going through that
process and the immigration Minister
Robert generic set out last week about
how we're looking for quite a lot of
former military bases or other similar
sites but is also actively considering
what can be done with some of these
floating vessels
Charities supporting those seeking
Asylum say both barges and military
bases are inadequate to those seeking
Sanctuary but soon a place that has
previously been the pride of Britain may
need to play a part in a different
challenge for the nation
ashnaharana Sky News endorse it
the social media appetite talk has been
fined 12.7 million pounds for failing to
protect the privacy of children an
investigation by the UK's data Watchdog
found that the app breached data
protection laws and didn't do enough to
prevent young children from using the
platform
a Russian anti-war activist accused of a
bomb attack which killed a pro-war
blogger has been formally charged Daria
trepova appeared in a court in Moscow
today and has been remanded in custody
until the 2nd of June the 26 year old is
facing terrorism charges over an
explosion at a cafe in Saint Petersburg
at the weekend
Buckingham Palace has released an image
of how invitations to the king's
coronation will look and it includes the
title Queen Camilla the first time
that's been used in an official capacity
a new photograph of the king and queen
has also been released
now it's not unusual to hear politicians
pledging to clean up politics but
pressure has been growing on the
government in recent weeks for their
failure to clean up the nation's rivers
and seas today the environment secretary
announced a plan in which contained
proposals to ban most kinds of wet wipes
but is she just recycling previous
announcements is our science
correspondent Thomas More
one tiny stretch of the River Thames in
West London and thousands of wet wipes
released by overflowing sewers are now
scattered along the shore the government
has announced plans for a new
consultation on Banning wipes containing
plastic you don't want that anywhere
near you but clean up volunteers are
weary it's the third consultation in
three years and the wipes keep piling up
we are disappointed with the time skills
and how long it's taking we realize it's
a step in the right direction and we'll
urge the government to swiftly take
action to ban plastic and wet wipes for
the sake of people and Wildlife
the government says its new water plan
will clean up Rivers there'll be
infrastructure upgrades to stop 10 000
sewage discharges that there were more
than 300 000 last year and there'll be
help for Farmers to stop farmyards
slurry running off their land we've got
a comprehensive plan for water that's
designed to tackle pollution at source
also how it's treated and to increase
the penalties on people who do the
polluting those penalties could be
unlimited but will they be enough one in
ten Rivers now fails ecological
standards just from sewage overflows
Rivers have effectively been used as
open sewers for decades taking
everything from industrial effluent to
human waste out to sea flush and forget
but campaigners say the government's new
plans for cleaning them up are too
little and too late is it comprehensive
it's got It's comprehensive in the list
of headlines that it's got within it but
has it actually got the detail has it
got the join up will there be the follow
through in this delivery to make this
happen on an issue that is absolutely
urgent and we need to see movement on
this dedicated delivery and action on
this far far faster than we've seen
today from defra increasingly dry
Summers add to the problems with too
much water diverted for irrigating crops
and Topping up reservoirs according to
environmental groups not a single River
in England is in good health and they
fear government plans fall well short of
solving the crisis Thomas More Sky News
now passengers traveling through London
City Airport will no longer have to
limit their liquids to 100 milliliters
following the introduction of new
scanners the limit for carrying liquid
in hand logo which would introduced in
2006 after Security Services formed a
liquid bomb plot here in the UK Emma
birchley has more
catch a plane over the past 17 years and
this has been the norm
stuffing mini bottles of decanted
toiletries each of a hundred milliliters
Max into a single plastic bag
but at London City Airport not anymore
thanks to the installation of new
sophisticated high-resolution scanners
they've been a significant investment
for us but we really believe in the new
technology it's cutting-edge technology
so we've gone from a 2D image on the old
security scanners and then we've got a
3D image now such that it gives the our
security officers so much more
information than they had previously
new machines can't be shown for security
reasons but they use the same technology
as CT scanners in hospitals now all you
have to do is get your tray and put your
bag straight in even if it's got liquids
laptop makeup in it and by simplifying
the process it's thought as many as a
third more passengers could get through
security every single hour
the security measures came in in 2006
after thwarted Terror attacks in which
suicide bombers plan to mix chemicals
hidden in drinks bottles to down
transatlantic flights
the new technology has been in use since
last month but the smaller T side
airport in Northeast England and other
UK locations are trialling the scanners
ready for the deadline to have them
installed by June of next year
is already making life easier for
passengers at City Airport I didn't
expect it I said this was probably the
easiest airport experience I've had in a
while we it's a connection flight and we
had all the water and all the baby food
in the bag so there was really
convenient we were surprised
the only problem is overseas airports
with the same security arrangements are
currently few and far between the advice
is to check first or risk having a
favorite family-sized Sun cream or
bottle of booze confiscated by Security
on the way home Emma birchley Sky News
East London
hello again from New York where this
Donald Trump saw part one of his day a
day that will culminate in a few hours
time when he gives remarks reacting to
today's events at his Mar-A-Lago Resort
in Florida our U.S correspondent Martha
Kellner joins us now from Florida Martha
yeah James Donald Trump currently still
aboard Trump Force One in the skies at
the moment over North Carolina in around
an hour's time he'll land at Palm Beach
International Airport he'll be greeted
there once again by his motorcade and
driven the 10-minute journey to his
luxury Mar-A-Lago estate which is where
I am Trump will then have around two
hours to freshen up to have perhaps a
final strategy meeting with his closest
aides who have traveled with him from
New York to Florida we then expect
around 8 15 p.m local time Donald Trump
to appear on the stage behind me this is
choreographed to strike the prime time
American Broadcast News audience this is
the first time we'll have heard from
Donald Trump since this indictment
became public knowledge last Thursday
this is his opportunity to eke out some
form of political Advantage from this
legal situation expect him once again to
go on the attack expect him to attack
the prosecutors responsible for bringing
these charges expect him to frame these
charges once again as politically
motivated expect him to to mention what
many are perceiving as significant
weaknesses in this case I think you can
also expect to see on the gold seats
behind me friends of Donald Trump
Associates perhaps Fringe members of the
Republican party and I think you can
tell from the distance we are from the
stage that any journalist no journalist
is likely to get a question to him this
will be a one-sided address the next
installment if you like of the Donald
Trump show
Martha many thanks
that's all from New York for now but
it's not the last we see of Donald Trump
here the next Hearing in this historic
case is scheduled for the 4th of
December that's two months before the
first Republican primary Donald Trump is
where the political and criminal
processes meet the